so this is pretty cool what me and nikki
are going to do right now uh and we
don't know what's going to happen we're
going to ask each other questions so you
guys get to learn about us and we get to
learn about each other we've actually
known each other for a very long time
but we have not prepped these questions
they're going to be spontaneous and
we're gonna hopefully find out things
about each other that we've never found
out before okay ladies first
gentlemen first no ladies first oh
darling okay i'll go first michael yo
yes what is your favorite movie of all
time hands down
gladiator
it's the best gladiator russell crowe is
the best movie out there because
every time it's on
no matter where it is in the movie i
have to watch it so nikki novak what's
your favorite food and why a hamburger
and french fries but my really favorite
most food
my favorite food is french fries i
cannot see a fry and turn one down and
sometimes i'll say to myself nick
order a salad yeah
and get a side of fries no you know what
i don't eat the salad first and then
you'll need a few fries it never works
out no you eat all the fruit here's what
you do you wanna know how to do it you
don't order fries at all you go to lunch
with a person and say can you order
fries and you just pick at their fries
so i got a question best new year's eve
ever
sometimes
it's the quiet ones that i like but i
would say the most spectacular new
year's i ever had was in sydney
australia whoa i was down at the harbor
bridge and it is so beautiful i'm sure
you've seen it on tv it's amazing how
about you oh
hands
down
about
20 years ago when charles barkley played
for the houston rockets i went to his
house i got invited to his house for a
new year's eve party
at midnight he opened up the
refrigerator and it was nothing but
chris stahl all in the everything oh it
reminded me of living in a snoop dogg
video it was in saint that's the best
new year's i've ever had and mike
no
he has and the second one is uh that is
the first time
on a cruise in hawaii i told my wife i
loved her right at midnight new year's
eve gave her her first uh i love you so
she would remember it and i made her
wait nine months for it i wanted her to
remember that for the rest of her life
shout out to clara what's up claire
claire what's up
you